After colonization of the whole world by about
14,000 years ago, stable populations grew larger, and were
insulated from the original populations from whence they
came. As a result, new traits emerged in various
regions that stayed regionally restricted. We had sickle
cell anemia in Africa as a protection against malaria.
The lactase persistance allele in milk drinking populations
of Europe and the Middle East began to grow.
And various skin pigmentation alleles to accommodate humans in
new climates with various penetrance of UV rays from the
sun began to appear. From humble beginnings, humans expanded
out of Africa into the rest of the world, creating
a vast array of alleles in brand new population.
It wasn't until about a few hundred years ago that
travel began to bring us all back together again. Leading
to mixing of the alleles between different populations at rates
like we've never seen before. Therefore, the resulting genetic
diversity has most likely had which of the following
effects? I want you to check any and all
that you think apply. The people are more homozygous for
more genes, or people are more heterozygous for more
genes? Are the population is better suited to survive
natural selection, or the population is less suited to
survive natural selection? Pick which answers you think are best.